and meanwhile the good news is the media
are going to tweet through it with them
so msnbc's stephanie rule she says
here's the good news you guys can enfor
you can afford inflation it's fine
you're fine stop whining
but you have to put all this in
perspective this inflation is not in
isolation and the government predicted
it was going to be a challenging
recovery recovery all tied to covid so
it's why you see things like that
expanded child tax credit you've got the
families of over 60 million kids on
average getting 430 dollars a month for
people on fixed incomes older people on
social security they're getting those
fixed payments adjusted next year of 5.9
percent for inflation and the dirty
little secret here willie while nobody
likes to pay more on average we have the
money to do so
okay on average we don't wages are not
rising as fast as inflation is everyone
knows it
but you know what when you got to push
the agenda you got to push the agenda
okay so there are unforeseen
consequences to the kind of democratic
behavior that we are seeing right now
hilariously there's only one group of
people who are really benefiting from
the inflation and it's state and local
governments okay so state and local
governments are raking in the tax
dollars according to the wall street
journal one irony of inflation is that
while it's bad for working americans
it's great for the government tax
revenues soar as nominal profits and
incomes rise and for evidence simply
look at the boom in state and local
government coffers they've rarely had it
so good but don't expect them to be
frugal spenders
overall state and local government
receipts including federal aid were 23
above pre-pandemic levels in the third
quarter through september thanks to
congress's gusher of spending and the
strong economic recovery according to
the committee for a responsible federal
budget
property corporate sales and individual
tax revenue from the third quarter of
2020 through the second quarter of this
year is running 18.3 above the same
period two years ago
how many americans have seen their
incomes rise almost 20 percent over the
last two years
like a lot of us
progressive states are doing especially
well they're whining about how they
don't have enough money they have plenty
of money
state and local tax revenue in new york
is running 13.3 billion dollars that's
21.3 percent higher for the current
fiscal year that began in april over the
same period in 2019 and by the way 2019
was a good year
california continues to report record of
monthly tax collections
and these rich states are receiving
plenty of welfare from from washington
congress has now given states and local
governments 885 billion dollars in
direct aid through various covet bills
for schools public transit medicaid and
more and now they're about to get
another helping from the infrastructure
deal
remember last year the states were
saying they were going to go bankrupt
yeah it was all a lie it's not true and
of course the federal government is
about to dump four trillion dollars more
in if they get billed back better pass
you can see why so many democrats are in
favor of all of this there's only one
problem it completely destroys economic
innovation it completely destroys the
ability of people to invest so great
exchange hilarious exchange between
bernie sanders and elon musk on twitter
yesterday so bernie sanders did his
usual thing okay bernie sanders says
this thing on twitter he says the world
is full of unfair things that happen all
the time i like fair things and i don't
like unfair things and third things are
bad
bad things are bad and then everybody in
his they go yay bernie
okay so that is bernie's twitter account
so bernie tweeted out we must demand
that the extremely worthy pay that for
sure period and bring me pudding
we must demand the extremely wealthy pay
their fair share now we've discussed ad
nauseam on this program how much the
wealthy pay in the united states and
it's all net income taxes in the united
states like all of it okay but
there's only one problem when you tell
people they have to pay their fair share
and when bernie sanders says for sure he
means pretty much everything everybody
knows so elon musk tweeted out i keep
forgetting you're still alive
yeah
harsh stuff there from from elon musk
boom okay and then he follows up there
he follows up on that one
and he says
would you like me to sell some more of
my stock because this is what he did
he says want me to sell more stock
bernie just say the word
he says bernie is a taker not a maker
this is correct okay so the bernie
sanders economic agenda the democratic
economic agenda hurts the economy it
makes inflation worse it creates
economic stagnation
they know this by the way so they have
to come up with an excuse the excuse
they're coming up with for their own
failed economic policy is alternatively
apparently kamala harris he's just being
taken and sacrificed to the great gods
of joe biden's political ambition
or covet right they keep blaming covet
so you had the white house national
economic council director
brian diese saying you know what all the
problems we're seeing right now they're
not joe biden's fault they're covin's
fault now here's the thing they're not
covered fault i know because i live in a
state where everybody is going about
their daily business like everything is
normal because it's normal now
but apparently it's all kovid's fault
certainly we saw just as the delta
variant
post real health challenges to the
economy i'd also had economic impacts
more people were consuming goods at home
watching tv rather than buying a new
television rather than going out to the
movies and spending on services and so
that's added to some of the supply chain
challenges that we face but we're seeing
these price increases as inflation
globally because of the supply chain
challenges associated with uh kovitt
that's why we're going right at
attacking those issues right now as well
so great it's it's all covered they're
going directly at the cove issues so how
are they going to solve covet so they
said they're going to solve the economy
and they proceeded to
basically act like a monkey screwing a
basketball
and that that is about an economic
policy a monkey just going to town on a
basketball so
so now they've done the same thing on
cover remember that that time that joe
biden said he wasn't going to shut down
the economy he was going to shut down
the virus remember that time and he shut
down the economy and not shut down the
virus so his plan has been that he's
going to force every employer in america
to force their employees to get
vaccinated that's only one problem
you're looking at countries all over the
all over the world and they have very
high vaccination rates and they are
still having breakthrough cases and
people who are unvaccinated are still
getting sick
that's just the way life is you got to
make your choice and then live with it
and go back to work and live your life
end of story but joe biden wants to be
seen as the guy who can fix all these
problems even though
again monkey
basketball that that does not make for a
successful mating
strategy okay so he's done that again on
the economy now it's a monkey screwing a
basketball on on covid
and um and it's a complete failure but i
think that he means for it to be a
complete failure because all he wants is
just not to be blamed
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed